and we're back yeah Happy New Year's
2018 we're back with Knievel it's been
two weeks for us one week for everybody
else yes but we did do that double
recording so we got twice as far
so somebody asked me where am i and I
was like I be the eyeball moosh guy the
dad the second time was eyeball moosh
where'd you get that
he's just moosh with eyeballs in it okay
and then I went on a ship and I fought
part of the game II probably did know
existed before but nightmare lady yeah
because that was completely hidden from
all the marketing oh yeah you've been
fighting young the little girl little
girl Evelyn
she's a nowhere the ring girl we're
loading up right now she's like super
creep yeah she so like you're Mia now
we're a family was the other dude Oliver
if you're not my mom I don't need you
anymore yeah she's okay so I'm still
still in this situation I met you know
what I'm actually I need your help
because I don't think I completely
remember what my goal was
you're just trying to find Ethan I don't
have a VHS but I have everyone tissue
tissue samples I have a chem fluid and I
haven't Oh a butt so I could mix these
and make some health but I'm gonna wait
because I might need bullies cuz I only
got two but I don't remember where I
came from
so I think you came from that way so try
this story okay check this floor out I
have no idea where I am that's the only
thing about recording two in a row that
kind of sucks like I don't know if this
is what I want to do
check out this floor first oh god it's
super dark
what's that noise do you hear it
I don't have enough bullets to kill
anything [ __ ]
why don't I wait no you had the machine
gun in that flashback when not present
well oh that's the computer she recorded
the message from the beginning of the
game on so you were here in the
flashback we am i am i had the girls do
yeah you definitely need a lockpick for
that orange box back there okay that's
good yeah and looks like a COBOL shoot
it open I feel like you should be able
to okay so now yours yeah but now you
know what you want to do I think the
stairs is blocked off where you came
from so using the elevator to get back
downstairs probably what you want to do
okay oh god I scared myself
alright I was a ladder and a hatch well
what's the poison wrench or something
oh god no little girl okay good like the
last thing you want to do when you like
climb up a ladder that biggest see a
little girl's face I don't like this
like all my from fear
[Music]
what stealth honorable so you went here
either in the flashback or yeah am i
there now like in my imprisoned times
present data I get confused a lot maybe
it still works
please know little girl okay I was just
there that's the save room right yeah
okay I was just there I don't remember
this place
Ethan I hope I make it in time enhance
enhance okay
let's go down whoosh let's some nail
marks near wrists [ __ ] hallucinations
where is she
just kidding I made them [ __ ] [ __ ] I
hate that little girl I'm like pretty
not interested in most Oh Lord what was
that gun paddock yeah yeah but okay
so I could make a health and some ammo
yeah because I have to Kim's thoughts
probably better off with ammo right now
you know the machine gun yet despite the
fact that you have rounds I know did I
do that wrong no just thinking you don't
have a machine gun you used to get
shotgun shells you got shotgun shells
and flame or feel before you got either
weapon Lord hmm that means they're gonna
[ __ ] be here no all right I'm gonna
make bullies okay mm-hmm
seems like a good thing
I just noticed this hey Mikey
got a bad day he's good he's super dead
uh you piece of work um I guess forward
we go oh I scared myself
I forget how remote bombs work you can
put it on the ground or the wall and
then you can I hold it yeah okay r2 and
then whatever else okay sorry I'm
nervous
Oh God
the captain's cabin should I go in there
mm-hmm maybe as a machine gun oh yeah
I'm really scared
they've done a good job in this one yeah
captain's key oh I don't know what that
is that has no value - yeah it does you
you saw something we did yeah where is
that captain did he go down with the
ship
oh well oh well oh god oh god where is
it oh it's is it this thing no that's an
elevator okay cool
[ __ ] and then there's this area oh this
is where it came from right yeah not
nuts right
actually this I would say my only issue
with this area is like it all looks the
same so I get really confused
alright well I guess I'm going down
those shitty stairs door back to you oh
that's another remote bomb hold on I
can't get in right yeah we're on the
same page here right yeah
what door you're right behind you down
that's a myth okay I just have a
bobblehead I don't know if you care at
this point under the stairs maybe
or above the stairs I hear it too
oh you little do I have a knife I don't
I don't think it's worth a bullet yeah
probably not at this point
can i melee it with my gun I don't think
so
it didn't work
see weak I would rather my bullets to be
honest with you that's too far so
he climbed up to the fourth floor now
you're on the third raise and now you
can go back down to the second I think
cuz I have this thing I think that's
looks gonna hurt me
I think that will kill me be good I know
I think that would kill me help you you
could go back to the I think it'd be
fine
well that is the long drop yeah let's
try it oh it is okay John no that hurt
me naughty good
oh is it this thing yeah got it
boo I don't wanna go down there what's
that noise I hear it do you hear it
yeah where am I going
you said Ethan will be down but it's up
to you whether you want explore the
second floor first maybe you'll find the
captain's key I'm not saying it cuz I
know I just forgot wait what's this then
there's a fuse yeah okay so I'll climb
up cuz I saw that guy Oh was that stick
him up
god
[Applause]
drop should I get the bomb down or what
you get shame in the face few times you
gotta love him old bull lows bullies I'm
rusty I'm rusty he's not
he's really close
okay leaves be dead suck shrapnel dick
is he dead hopefully
something tells me we're in the right
room Oh night live infant this 16 years
since the nightmare of Raccoon City ooh
one of the few references to earlier
games yay okay so that's it unless I'm
missing something he crouched under
there nope okay so I'm gonna make more
bullets
okay that seems right right that seems
smart cha we're on the same page here
cuz there's another guy you're looking
for a fuse to repair the elevator is
that right cuz I can go down without it
oh god what's that noise
should go in this room Oh Lord stairs no
no I don't know it's dark oh the ship
sucks
no whammy no whammy no whammy hmm this
is a good area open that cheese no
maggots no maggots mm not worth it do I
know what you get honestly you don't
know the prize it's not don't worry
about it we're only playing this once Oh
God
all right so what's the prize Liza
Minnelli us what was that
I hear it
he's like right outside this goddamn
door shooter in the fast balls oh he's
so gross
where is arms go
but [ __ ] god damn it Mary I really don't
have the bullets to do that they did it
again
like cou like flips around like that
very erratic and rock
I got one where are your arms you can't
open this door and left right that's it
you need a liquid
I need a liquid but there was another
door this double door what sick ah
there's some boxes here right was that
do you want to go get those bubbles no
sicker do you check that room behind you
the wooden door was that were you and
Oliver were whatever his name is it's
taking me a while to go through this
space because it's so scary
Allen not Oliver Allen Oliver's from
call me by your name what was that the
movie Oh corrosive
um I'm gonna keep everything because I
have the room mm-hmm I'm gonna try save
real fast sure I might as well get two
bobbleheads you can unlock that tackle
box upstairs this area is a pretty big
bummer and you can corrosive door down
the hall is there you don't like this
area yeah it just stresses me out
everything looks the same to the
untrained eye that's good
it's more of an monotonous than the
mansion maybe two people that spend a
lot of times on ships feel normal
oh my god
you got the bullets in the room back
there right
oh that's for the thing totally worth it
nice okay this is worth it doing a good
look see here
okay I feel good all right so what do
you think lockpick first or what
probably lockpick and the captain's
cabin I think around the same floor so
it doesn't matter well there's a bobble
head in here if you want to get that
first yeah you hit that with your knife
from here could be wrong can I throw the
knife no maybe you can lunge off swing
on the way down okay no that ladder
kicked in I shoot
like you where your head's at oh this
Supply Management oh it's all that
matters
what about this Dumbledore have we done
this oh god what was that
I hear him my [ __ ] prototype dude
this is definitely a time for bombs
be dead great
I hope there's only one
oh right I remember that the kitchen
hole okay but you might have got done in
the past and not in the present I'm
trying to remember
yeah that's why it's so confusing right
Oh God bullets
I need that machine gun yeah whoo little
booties all right that's the original
pile that you scanned that was leading
you to Evelyn let me know if you see
something I don't
who's that noise
you hear it
yeah sounds like like a gross liquid
I don't know what this is
look
this is a puzzle I think okay let's talk
about it so they're really into like
postmodern Impressionism
this one's upside down
that one is got red on the bottom and
this one's got pink on the upper left
that did I do a version oh oh well
that's great
triple row okay gonna be like triple
Cobra yeah this place was lavish before
it got [ __ ] up yeah those ships are
pretty fancy so sorry am I going down or
am I going up now go back up for the and
go up for now
was it third had this had a corrosive
door and I think it had a lockbox - I
think so yeah it's my voice just cracked
yeah becoming a man cuz that nothing is
happening down there lockbox is right
here okay captain's quarters up here as
well gimme gimme-gimme-gimme
machine gun mm-hmm wait what do you use
those for now well not I got I scared
myself he's just a little
oh my god he's become the [ __ ]
what weight the room behind you wasn't
there this is this is no time oh he went
into the floor
when do they do that
that's the first I hear it
well it's bullets book half is good
just thought I'd try it again
I have corrosive yum-yum-yum
the captain's key that's downstairs I
think but I thought it was up here oh
god where am I
let me in no you're gonna do this to me
now just look a lot let me in I know how
to walk forward oh oh this is where she
finally like grabbed you shut up
Oh check out the Vista no that's where
dogs come from think it's huge it's nice
what are those balls fuel tanks of some
sort maybe
me no likey this whole area God God it's
too dark I'm full I'm gonna make some
bullets that sound like a good call I
have four cams and I could make a health
but I mean I guess I can wait because I
haven't gotten hit in a while actually
just when I said that I realize it
probably shouldn't make bullying what
what is it check behind you there is
something there
I don't
I'm gonna die what's happening you up
Arwen I [ __ ] took too long to
remember the lesson auto safety I was we
got the power cable for the elevator she
saved damn it fat molded of the vomer
yeah that sucks I should have had a
health at the ready I was dumb do I even
need to stay in there okay I didn't lose
very much like do I even need to be in
there no like do I need to stay because
my my thought is to just get the thing
and run right thoughts yeah if you want
to there's another door on the other
side you can go through over here I
think I don't try it you're right
yeah now well you didn't get the power
cable yet but that's when he comes after
me do you need it yeah but it's
literally an objective you check here
you press pause and say like restore
power to the elevator whatever alright
alright okay ready go go girl go hurry
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry there's no
time stick around
wait I'm gonna laugh so hard he's locked
[ __ ] why is that that we're not open
that's the ticket that I'm talking
telling you okay run sprint run
I've run so slow don't [ __ ] block and
run yeah Savitz Jukes you [ __ ]
bouncing I'm so slow I'm like trotting
here
is there anywhere else I need to go like
see like normally it goes it's locked
yeah I don't know why I didn't take you
out all right am I going in here
wait did you check the rest of this
floor the captain's room is up here I
think you're safe now relatively oh god
I hear it mr. Baum is coming um what's
in the captain's room machine gun right
I do need that just saving because I
have anxiety sorry okay
I hate that guy okay so
captain's log does this say
captain's cabin for hmm is that it yeah
that makes sense he's on top oh oh you
gotta climb the ladder right from the
elevator yeah I got it it's just that
balmy Magoo is out there I'm balmy Magoo
and the aluminum monster well you could
put the power cable yeah that noise is
your inventory Pole yes what's that
noise what is it do you hear it yeah
I have one slot I got one hot slot
[Music]
where's the captain
No
oh [ __ ] I got really hurt give health
yes
can I use it sure like I have to make it
oh I only have strong chem left yeah I
could eat it I can just eat one no your
check your watch I think you're on red
doesn't have one
yeah press uh touchpad oh you look like
you're really hurt
I think I think making a sweet you got a
machine gun now I have to make a fancy
one is that okay yeah all right and then
eating ready bloody I'm gonna eat it
you're gonna eat an Arab or use the whoa
what do you want to do yeah I would use
it just use it yeah regrow cool alright
I feel a lot better with this ammo so
there was like a little uh you know
spider-man around here but I don't think
I need to hit him because I have
everything I need so I could just that's
too far right yeah I think so for me to
fall the bobblehead oh right your left
wasn't he down here yes you're right now
[ __ ]
where is it
seriously the [ __ ] what's up with that
music you heard it right yeah he's on
the third floor
hopefully can't come through there
it's a much bigger knife and even head I
was trying big dumb idiot
alright well what would you recommend
you could put the power cord thing in
the elevator where's that well I got a
fall though remember yeah you think I'm
okay keep yawning I that earthquake woke
me up this morning
what was that help me tell me what to do
God okay so I go down here yeah you
should be able to put that power cord in
I can't mow see you put that in and then
you also need the fuse which is probably
the floor below you yeah and then you
also need a fuse did I do it I don't
think so I think you need a few but
press X on that yeah you need music yeah
you never went down yet well there's a
reason for that reason is that it sucks
down there be a more corrosive now
that's gonna save me
Dorian been there yet shut up oh god I
can hear it where is it
the music
you got him they do it yeah feel like I
wasted a lot of bullets know pretty much
what it would take with that gun
it's a weak gun is it I'm just like it's
a very high-stress situation so I'm not
really interested in like hanging out
here book I heard that she's waving that
thing at people when you walk into rooms
where is it where is it
he's in there isn't he I have to voice
my opposition to you just holding the
remote bomb yeah where is he he must be
on the other side of door right we're on
the same page here I was taking a nap my
bunkie did you feel that earthquake
Weston yes I did it woke me up and I
couldn't sleep afterward I was half
asleep and I heard a kid oh it will be
the last second of it woke me up so I
only felt like a second of it but other
people felt like ten seconds it screams
like a little girl and ran for it
Giovani Finetti wait what go back that's
a sick named Giovanni Finetti he's
written everything he's known he's given
up the ghost
you missed he like said like I scream
like a little girl they're [ __ ]
definitely in here it's a crew quarters
did it come from the Amazon oh Lisa Dom
oh nice so nice all right you [ __ ]
I heard you crying in here where is he
hey how's it going Janet
tried talking a little girl her dad shot
me this nasty look that letter is pretty
stupid
that lifejacket on the ground to your
left had X thing on it
nothing that a shotgun shell I don't why
did it let me have this I
[Music]
why why Resident Evil it I don't know
I'm not doing it wrong right how weird
okay that's very weird oh god it's so
[ __ ] dark in here Oh God
oh this sucks let me in let me in let me
in let me in let me man you drinking
that stuff
Jesus cool cool
this is a good it's a good place got a
ping-pong table okay
this yeah yes it is a clinic Forrest
Gump Hey oh my god why do I have so many
of those and a volleyball and a is that
a I don't even know
okay I'm ready to go oh my god this area
is so scary
no here a bobblehead maybe not
there's something in here
fuse yeah well we know what's gonna
happen oh wow what that's not it's got
me somewhere down
I have to give them a fuse how many
fuses do I need there's machine-gun I
hear it top right there
I hear it
I don't know where it is the [ __ ] is
down there should go down there did you
go through the double door yet right
there I've been through [ __ ]
down damn
nope sorry Jesus he like does all these
fake deaths like where he's like playing
dead oh this area is too long for how
much like anxiety it causes all right
let's just go I guess
yeah so do I want to go in there first
and check yeah check the rumor can I
take it oh okay so okay you can bring it
back so I don't want that right okay so
where you put it on the elevator I go
back and check out that room you said
before was it this one now huh
and do anything
yeah I don't I bet it does
I just
like I'm sure it does something I just
don't know I don't know all right okay
that was weird
there's obviously like a secret all
right so now what I go down here no
go back on the elevator and put a fuse
in okay I hate this area okay I know
what so where am I going
oh god you could say it first
I never save room on this floor
we're doing okay mm-hmm that was really
stressful so now you just take the
elevator down a to F or whatever was
okay I'm gonna put this point away cuz I
don't need a sub level to it's great
yeah
like what would I do with it I don't
know why it's that way yeah so I've
saved and I put away a coin and it came
from that way so I am oh wait now I'm
taking the elevator that's it right yeah
bed bomb men's laugh
he's waiting shut I hate this [ __ ] she
sucks she's scaring me I'm perfect
sweetheart come on out
bless you your little child I see it
it's on the ceiling
is that even a danger to you
yeah yeah [ __ ] you up morale is high
okay I actually I'm pretty I'm pretty
good here I could make I could make some
bullies but I don't know what do you
think should I just hang out I got 164
here yeah you're fine
well let pump your guts full of lead one
to ten
who's that guy's head I have a lot uh
remote bombs I have nine yeah should
start using them quite a few oh you've
been down here before the flashback
balls
[ __ ] you
oh my God look how many [ __ ] bombs
are in here like ten what am I going to
do with all of these
light up some his arms there's our zoms
in this game we're all soon me reach for
the sky hey [ __ ] bomb you stupid
[ __ ] I hate this girl so much [ __ ]
there's like nowhere to run there's like
this pole a this like very tiny safety
pole here that's it what is that
twitching
I'm the Mona
nohe day now you're good
I got like 10 more bombs so bring it on
what was that that a farmer
I think so yeah [ __ ]
[Music]
luckily I have several 14 I didn't do
that
[Music]
stay down
the loaders from the last of us um like
a little bit but I'm Way more familiar
with boomers from left 4 dead
sir oh my god he's dead
check his pulse why am I still getting
mo some heavy bass keys no tickling the
ivories
let me sound weird
giving you this
carry over in a New Game+ maybe why am i
sounding so weird I don't know okay now
there's another room over there hold on
hold on
hey where you're going this is remember
the flashback this is where no I
remember but first got corrosives
well I used all my corrosives
oh [ __ ] what am i doing alright is there
like a little girl in here god damn it I
knew it
[Music]
no you're in timeout even Ethan hey
little dude how you holdin up I goes
rock watch it just says it's red Ethan
who the part was scary
wait shh it's the dad hey a lot never
would have if I could've helped
what do you mean I'm no killer son
neither is Marguerite normal boy Lucas
or even Zoe here that girl Evelyn
she did this what the hell is she
now what did she do to you she infected
us with her gift that's what she calls
it I found her
yeah busted out tank and the Bayou Oh he
adopted her everything changed after
that
so she infects you and then she takes
control no not exactly sir she just she
forces away into your mind you saw
you can't fight back oh this is sad you
are connected to her and you can't
resist the urge to oh you're a new
different person after that just like me
huh
Sonia sent me that message because of
Evelyn listen and you're just lots of
family are wrong
she's the key all right you find her you
stop
if
free my family please oh geez
now I feel bad for them yeah they're
still trying to kill you pretty hard
though yeah I remember
riho there's no time I have health packs
you have to get out of it here take this
what are you doing you need to go I
won't be able to resist for much longer
no no Kevin [ __ ] Mia
[Music]
get dammit I have no things no I put all
effort okay [ __ ] what [ __ ]
ever in a finding stuff it's like so
debilitating to like get nothing what is
that dude say something Oh me didn't you
hear that yeah I need a gun my most
whiny Oh voices might know I noticed I'm
trying to I need a good I'm just gonna
be fighting this little girl with a fish
what's that noise slapping her with
smallmouth bass was that talking fish
thing
[Music]
don't act like you don't remember
I'm talking fish night on the wall yeah
I know
is there [ __ ] alligators in this game
no that's an alligator I don't
No are you talking about some fish isn't
it
it's a bayou
alligators are everywhere and buyers oh
it was an unsubstantiated wait wait go
back
go left over toward that I just have
anxiety about alligators is this
alligator related no not yet
in the DLC go uh yeah walk over toward
the bank yeah yeah I did not want you to
miss that okay cool
nice
oh my god I'm so afraid of alligators I
don't like anything in the water you
know like murky water like all that
stuff like really freaks me out
alligators sharks piranhas water snakes
any kind of water thing excuse me
grave anxiety moccasins my brother
almost got bit by a water moccasin no
way South Carolina that's how you died I
didn't go
Abercrombie salt mine hmm
there was a collapse in the Patterson
mine twon and Beck field are dead and
Huxley will never walk again old man
Stan was right the ground is too
unstable any replacements they went us
to work double shift instead I can't
wait to get back to the old country
oh that's America for EM oh you got no
legs better work harder than ya it's a
helicopter
it's a weird perspective are they
watching I don't know if you could see
what the logo on there is it it's an
umbrella umbrella psycho stems did you
find anything
thorough search of the Baker property
revealed zero survivors repeat zero
survivors we did find evidence of a
skirmish
Edelin negative however we did find
several encrypted messages from the
Baker son Lucas to an unknown third
party you can probably guess who that
was
that's just great we've had reports
isn't you abandoned mine south of the
property I'm gonna go have a look Roger
that we'll meet you at those coordinates
if you encounter Evelyn orders are shoot
to kill
repeat shoot to kill the cages
so let me ask you this does that mean
that all right I did um is that mean I
don't go back to the old place anymore
this is probably a good time down the
episode though I think next episodes be
finale of resin evil resin can even come
again there yeah Wow you're kidding so
like now it starts to sound like the
first Resident Evil like alpha and Bravo
seems try to investigate a mansion yeah
I didn't realize it was that far in
but there's those coins in just so you
got real did you I did okay I didn't I
don't have enough I need three more I'm
getting there though I had her hand
I cannot store this yep
p19 machine gun enhanced and gun ammo
you could do this next time you're so
jog your memory oh sweet I'm gonna save
that was good it's very scary that whole
boat area is like the like II really
that's crazy so I don't know it's a bit
like bittersweet yeah seven yeah people
are asking if we're do anything after we
can figure that out yeah let's talk
about it on the next cable episode this
was the penultimate literally this was
the penultimate Resident Evil I said
that last time and you said it wasn't
true no this one was oh yeah yeah right
you're a penultimate for once you were
right